do you guys remember that time that
Princess Zelda basically doomed her
entire timeline to fail and then was
miraculously saved by the good graces of
well Lady Luck no well then allow me to
remind you see for those of you who have
played the Wind Waker you'll probably
recall that whenever a new game is
started the first thing you see is a
lengthy prologue cutscene detailing the
events of the land of Hyrule leading up
to the Wind Waker for those of you who
have played ocarina of time you'll
probably recognize the fact that a good
Oh nearly half of the entire cutscene is
detailing the events of Ocarina of Time
this is further solidified when the
cutscenes straight up states that the
hero of legend they're referring to is
known as the hero of time which as some
people may not know actually only refers
to a single link in particular you know
this guy this is all well and good and
hearing how the good old hero of time
beat Ganon who you may or may not have
heard of before this point just leaves a
warm fuzzy feeling in your heart the
cutscene serves to prove several things
in a meager two or three minutes of
runtime it disproves the all Zelda games
are retelling the same event theory
helps to prove the existence of and
solidifies the wind wakers place in the
adult timeline and even hints at the
reincarnation of the spirit of the hero
on the board does it you see the
cutscene takes a turn in a twist of plot
that ever since I played the game for
the first time when I was a child I
always thought was really weird as we
know from the events of the game that we
see further on the goddesses took things
into their own hands and flooded Hyrule
when Ganon returned and why did they do
this you ask well it all comes down to
five simple words stated plainly and
clearly in the prologue when evil crept
back into the land the people of Hyrule
believed the hero of time would save
them but the hero did not appear evil
had returned the people had panicked and
their faith and the gods was tested but
the hero was nowhere to be found
[Music]
as with many things in zelda lore it all
comes back to ocarina of time in the
events of the game as some will recall
and others will well spoiler warning
Zelda and link plot to defeat the man
with the evil eyes by use of the
legendary Master Sword
upon opening the door of time that led
to the blade however in one of the
coolest twists ever done in the history
of gaming it was brutally revealed to
the player that their actions had
actually enabled Ganondorf to access the
Triforce resting within the Sacred Realm
as link was put to sleep for seven long
years only to awaken to a future riddled
with ganondorf's evil enter the adult
timeline fast forward to the end of the
game and Link and Zelda are able to
harness the power of the sages the hero
and the Master Sword to seal Ganon away
and restore peace to the land for a time
after the fight were shown a pivotal
cutscene that details the Princess Zelda
attempting to remedy her mistakes you
see it was her fault that Ganondorf had
access to the Sacred Realm in the first
place this whole Master Sword defeating
evil thing as you'll recall was her idea
her burden which is why she decided to
send link back to the original timeline
the child timeline her remedy but while
she may have saved the child timelines
Hyrule from Ganondorf seven year reign
by sending link back to her child self
the adult timeline lived on without the
hero of time
princess Zelda's new adult timeline that
she alone was left to protect had new
rules you see there was a princess there
was the evil that was sealed away
temporarily there were the goddesses but
there was no longer a hero enter the
prologue to the Wind Waker no I can hear
you thinking is M&B really insinuating
that a complete timeline of The Legend
of Zelda lacks the spirit of the hero
well yes but also no you see if we look
at the events of the Wind Waker with
this new idea in mind there are certain
things that start to make sense
several times in the game the hero of
winds is compared directly to the hero
of time only to conclude that he is not
in fact the legendary hero the great
Deku Tree immediately begins speaking in
the ancient Hylian tongue once link
saves him from his acne
problem it's ok buddy we've all been
there thinking he was the hero of time
from ages past which the great Deku Tree
had met before long ago however once you
play the game over in Hero Mode you the
player can actually understand this
ancient language being spoken
it's then revealed that he conclusively
states link is not of the hero of time
in a similar situation later on in the
game when Lincoln the king of Red Lions
are meeting with the great fish gaboon
while he's in hiding the two share a
conversation that the player can only
understand one side of again until you
play the game over in hero mode
it's then revealed that the conversation
goes a little something like this it
must mean you have found the hero of
time
does it not unfortunately that is not so
then for what purpose have you come to
see me the one I have brought with me
has no connection to the legendary one
and yet I sense great promise in the
courage that this one possesses promise
you suggest that I leave the fate of
Hyrule up to mere chance I do it is the
only way um rude am i right
I mean link is literally sitting right
there Joe Boone where are your manners
ah but proper insulting etiquette aside
the game goes out of its way to state
over and over that the hero of winds is
not connected to the hero of time how
odd but could this really mean that the
timeline lacks the spirit of the hero
well combined links disconnect from the
hero of time with the actions of the
goddesses they flooded Hyrule think
about that for a second the goddesses
the ones who created the entire world of
the Legend of Zelda when Ganon reared
its ugly head instead of raising a hero
to meet the evil head-on as they've done
countless times they decided then to
drown the world and its inhabitants with
hopes of defeating Ganon once and for
all if this still seems odd to you
that's because it should could it be
that the goddesses didn't call upon
another link because they couldn't I
mean think about all the extra measures
taken to ensure Ganondorf doesn't
consume the world once more they froze
Hyrule in time by using the Master Sword
as its key they literally split the
individual pieces of the Triforce of
courage that link left behind when he
left this timeline and hid those pieces
across the Great Sea and even split the
Triforce of wisdom all in attempts to
hide there
powers from Ganondorf these are all
really extreme measures that have never
before been seen used to hinder Ganon's
evil isn't it probable that this is
because the spirit of the hero the only
one who could rise up to defeat Ganon
was gone now entered the hero of winds
so okay there's no spirit of the hero in
the adult timeline so what exactly does
that make the hero of winds just some
brave boy that just so happened to get
caught up in all this because his sister
just so happened to get taken away by
some large burb yes that's exactly who
he is
he didn't have the Triforce of courage
he wasn't born with the spirit of the
hero he's just a boy who made the choice
to risk his young life to save not only
his little sister from the clutches of
evil but also the entire world because
of his immense show of courage he was
chosen by the master sword in a very
similar tone to Ocarina of Time link did
end up bringing the completed Triforce
to Ganondorf but because of the king of
Hyrule swish was able to drown away the
old Hyrule once and for all along with
the king of Hyrule the Master Sword and
the king of evil Ganondorf he and the
princess go on to found the new Hyrule
within which the events of Spirit Tracks
take place along with a new hero
I believe this kid the hero of winds was
just a regular boy who became the new
hero whose spirit was then taken after
he passed away by the goddesses to
become the new spirit of the hero for
the adult timeline meanwhile over in the
child timeline the original spirit of
the hero of time continued on and even
made an appearance in the next game
Twilight Princess as a ghost yet makes
no such appearance anywhere in the adult
timeline but let's bring this back to
Princess Zelda this video is actually
about her after all this is her legacy
yes she almost ended up allowing Ganon
full reign over the world but I say this
in no disrespect to her how many kids do
you know around the age of 10 that are
contemplating saving the world I mean in
a serious sense not your little sibling
running around with the toy sword
slaying the boogeyman but really even as
a young girl with her whole life ahead
of her she was cursed with visions of
oncoming evil
she had to act on it was her
responsibility but she didn't ask for it
if she did nothing who knows what
ganondorf's true plans were but when she
did do something about it and tried to
get to the master sword she messed
things up anyway her character is so
complex that it's a wonder she's not
depressed all the time
she bore the weight of the world on her
shoulders while link received all the
glory for defeating evil and the praise
for becoming the hero of legend and
although she may have nearly lost it all
her actions ultimately led to victory
over ganondorf's evil schemes across
every timeline and that is the story of
how Princess Zelda almost doomed the
world of Hyrule hey guys thank you so
much for watching this was a really fun
one that I greatly enjoyed making for
you and if you enjoyed watching it
please leave a like to get it spread
around on YouTube also make sure you
subscribe to the channel with that Bella
Con so you don't miss out when I upload
more nuggets of epicness as I am known
to upload as always huge thanks to my
patrons who make my day every day if
you're interested in supporting the
channel in getting your name featured at
the end of all of my videos follow the
link in the description below to find
out how also down there are links to my
social media pages so come on over and
say hi that's all I've got for you in
this one so of course I hope you have a
great rest of your day this is mask
Nintendo bandits signing out peace
[Music]